hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the Blair Witch the
Blair Witch hi this is Ellis hey how you
doing
[Applause]
yeah why wouldn't you anyway I'm nearby
just wait for me there okay yeah yeah
let's go back :
yeah okay let's just go back the way we
came yeah let's just do that that sounds
good
sent it through the rocks yes through
this pass in the rocks went straight to
the tree there's got to be a tape that I
can rewind that's gonna allow me to see
that okay hey don't talk to me like I'm
crazy
screw you in it I don't need your help
it's you who needs me now I'm the only
person is gone forest who's even
remotely close to finding that kid
Emmit you there Emmett goddamn it
poom okay alright um that's a little
weird but I'm not surprised by the
multiple reality alright whoa whoa whoa
I see you I see it or I see it alright
what is that is so fast what is that oh
I got a text message is perfect time for
it err it's a good boy I took the
message there's no reception huh health
moving is always better than standing
thing's not making any games those who
don't move have a 99% chance of dying
better start walking okay okay good good
pop I don't know what those things are
that are zip zapping around the woods oh
you make everything seem alright okay I
can go back to the bridge that I just
came from not a hundred percent sure
well it just got quiet
it's just cut real quiet there's some
kind of a light that's pouring out over
there I don't know what that's from
okay so there's clearly nothing over
here maybe I gotta go back towards that
bunker again or or or something because
I'm willing to bet that I wasn't
supposed to open it the way that I did
but I did and it's too late and there's
nothing I can do about it but at least I
could go back I don't know try to find
something where's the path
okay now I've lost sight of the path
wait what wait weird with the path in
the rocks go look higher between the
leaves I don't wanna I don't wanna
I don't wanna I'm not seeing anything
higher I'm not seeing anything between
the leaves okay I'm gonna try to go back
the way I came I don't know how I miss
the entranceway was it there's a light
over there I don't know if it's
something I've already seen before if
it's something new and it's gone I have
no idea where it went
god I'm gonna get lost so easily in
these woods I'm gonna get so lost
ooh hello hope oh hey good boy good boy
you you guide me through wherever the
hell we're going I got your boy see oh
wait what what down wait isn't it it's
Blaney's car but how it was a complete
wreck just a moment ago yeah good
question yeah a very good question
commitment I know you're there I just
found your car come on i'ma talk to
channel 3 say the left channel 3 say the
light anyone hear me
the light the light the light say the
light say the line I say the light the
light what who is this hello yeah what
the hell not yeah why the hell not yeah
why not
locked of course oh good job buddy
good good good boy good boy you're such
a good boy that's a good boy
oh no no way here getting the truck what
do you mean wait here
don't leave your poeple out there poeple
come here a fuse panel okay this is
probably important oh look daddy oh boy
okay so front light 20-amp cavity seven
Oh 20 amps four seven and nine what's
this another missing person officer
Wilson was notified of the disappearance
of Todd McKinnon by Adam Braun according
to his testimony McKinnon was supplying
him with timber when he suddenly stopped
about
two weeks ago Brown was unable to
establish stand in front of contact with
MacKinnon the initial search yielded no
results MacKinnon could not be found in
his home MacKinnon had no known history
of mental health problems currently
examined hypothesis deliberate
disappearance 2015 1830
oh that's time that's time that's not a
date
that's not a year MacKinnon's neighbors
claim that he was frequently visiting a
defunct sawmill and tapis creek timber
company in the Black Hills forest okay a
little weird
[Music]
oh no battery I should take a look under
the hood okay 20 amps in seven and nine
that's what I need
hey Bob you're good boy very good boy
okay battery seems to be off for some
reason okay well it wait there while I
inspect the hello fuses that explains it
take 20 and seven and nine the only
other 20 is right there's good oh pardon
pardon me yeah hey buddy noise now I'm
really losing at this time aren't I oh
no that's exactly
you're a good boy you're a good boy
you're a real good boy doc you a good
boy listen don't worry about how reality
is all weird and whatnot you just stick
by my side you stay real close close to
me stay close and we'll be fine even
though this doesn't make any sense at
all okay yeah let's just uh let's start
this whole adventure over again then
shall we huh okay
oh hi bullet are you doing let's go
no not you now you what the hell whoa
I keep getting bumped to your voicemail
anyway I was just calling hi I don't
know why really been thinking a lot
about us lately you're avoiding me are
still running around the woods
anyways calling uh-huh I don't really
know why I've been thinking about us a
lot lately call me when you can bye I
guess I could call if I got any cell
service just a little bit though hey
Jess will isn't it a bit early for you
no no no no it's it's good to hear your
voice listen I'm sorry about before
seems all I do is apologize and then I
say something stupid again it's like
we're trapped in the neverending cycle
of [ __ ] hey as long as we're getting
paid we were good for a while oh hey hey
so bullet bullet bullet
my life happened yeah happy line more
than yours you got a job yeah yeah I
better get to it
call you later okay okay all right bye
Jess hey good to hear from you also time
so real weird it was night now today he
I just put up fuse in a car that
shouldn't have been there where are we
both where are we all it come here yeah
yeah yeah you stick by me you stay close
stay close bullets stay close I know
that you wanted to do that but don't do
that
yeah some tell me this whole endeavor is
a little not worth it but sure okay this
is cool though like I like this surreal
nosov it like getting in the wasps
getting lost in the woods it's like
early childhood memory for me like the
woods were what I was all about when I
was a kid I live to go out in the woods
and like the concept of just getting
lost in the heart of things that exist
out in the woods no it's a weird thing
smoking huh well if I don't gave you
this
ooh footprints hey footy-prints so
someone's been here at least a little
bit recently yeah what you got Bob oh
I'm not moving Emily
what'd you find what'd you find what'd
you find bullet that's very much I don't
like it either
let me take a look in the Beyonder Jesus
Christ
Gabey and we were just I don't
understand
Oh God Lanie Oh God look you don't you
deserve better than this [ __ ] lettings
badge ah
no one has served him more than him neck
wound deep then his head is cool oh gods
really hanging on ah
the killer Oh skin this face clean cuts
probably postmortem completely different
mo than the decapitation won't
what decapitation won't what
decapitation oh that I thought there was
a separate murder
okay I'm not dumb I get that there was a
almost near decapitation wound going on
right there oh hello Lenny was tough
experienced letter Q were surprising it
had to be someone he knew ah a detective
are you now
Anita one of those people are I don't
know but they're all staring at a wall
all weird like that
I wonder if this game is gonna answer
the question of why they would stare at
walls maybe the witch doesn't like
looking at yeah but like are you looking
at them okay so this is bad why the
shovel isn't there anything weird about
the shovel there it's not like they even
tried to bury him whoever it was clearly
a witch bullet I'm sorry I know it's
it's no good hey what were you doing up
there well the way you got
what
what what
but you see how this doesn't make any
sense at all
what were you doing here sure this is no
longer just a missing person case come
on bullet we got to finish this okay but
there yeah there's something that must
change here with this what was it
shovel it's it's the shovel from the
video I'll get him for this Lanie I
swear you think I could rewind the
murder happening but apparently not come
here boy sniff this horribly bloody
shovel sniff it your boy see if you can
find nothing there huh yeah that's a
little oh good goodbye what what's up
what's up what's up what's up up okay
sheriff Emmitt Lanting guy who cares
yeah I think and everyone even me really
sorry I hate but
never gave up not even after let him
down
I'll find the man who did this do you
think I should like radio to somebody
about this and also you know not be
worried why was he just hanging out with
the guy that murdered him being all
chill why would he do that yeah okay
hang on let me check in here first
there's some something going on oh
another one yeah contravening article 52
of the North Carolina General Statutes
publicly disrespects and shows contempt
for national symbols our military
service and the patriotic soldiers he
had once had the honor of serving with
alright well okay what does that have to
do with anything weird I feel like I've
said that like more than any other
singular words weird because everything
here is just bizarre I have no idea
what's happening I feel like I'm getting
lost in the woods but somehow keep
follow I whoa what other wanna go the
right way back whoa I'm going crazy he's
so crazy like things change but I've
only vaguely remember things being one
way and another and this isn't oh wow
what happened
oh no it's happening I don't know what's
going on with that that's weird
Wow boy hi I have no I have no idea I
have no idea what's a full bullet but
where's bullet I don't see bullet
anymore
bullet please do leave me bullet I'm why
in the hell oh it's the great Deku Tree
no not now
no what not now oh no oh no oh hi bullet
all it have I ever mentioned how good a
boy you here bullet bullet please going
boy well it plays just doesn't feel like
a good idea bullet this feels like a
very bad idea
this feels like the worst idea that I
could possibly do bullet I feel oh
that's bizarre
what
on its own yeah a little weird huh okay
Fabian all it where'd you go Oh No thank
you I don't want any oh I would rather
not hi hello what hi okay I can't see
where I'm going I can't see anything
what are you doing to be pull it oh boy
oh no well where are you boy please boy
please ah oh oh those okay that's
nothing okay it's a whole lot of nothing
it's just a bunch of nothing happening
to everybody in here oh hi how are you
doing hey let me crash down here this
feels good this feels great I like this
bullet are you buddy hey who's a
handsome boy who's got dark roots Oh
another one
great and a lot of them this one doesn't
have a name also I'm not really seeing
anything in it Lucas all right I don't
really see a Lucas in earbud sure all
right where's that whoa are you maybe I
shouldn't just be showers all it bullets
stuck
bullet please Oh let's do something
behind me I'm wiggling
I'm Wiig waggling there we go God oh
it's weird the field of view also it's
just expanding at an exponential rate oh
where are you where are you buddy yeah
buddy
pull it okay this is fine just crawl
them through it over where I'm sorry
could you whisper that again in my ear
all right so you're trying to dick with
me is what you're doing well oh I got
rest ception did in this hellhole
beneath the tree I have one new voice
message
okay that's good to know she is here are
you talking about the Blair Witch is I'm
sorry what about my census my senses
seem to be a little bit Jabberwocky at
the moment I don't seem to be able to
make heads or tails of anything in here
seems to just be topsy-turvy also my
ability to run is significantly
diminished if you can just point me to
the exit and on my dog I've greatly
appreciated miss witch or can I call you
Blair well
that's okay I definitely have PTSD of
some case something's going on here I
don't think you want me I'm damaged
goods at this point yes no but maybe huh
don't promise me with a good time don't
threaten me off the record Ellis what
what what the hell happened yes I wanted
to a robbery call when you got there you
saw them leaving the store you took out
your gun you told them to stop the kid
reached for something
was it a weapon no and then what oh you
know what happened
Adam Shannon Peters brother I don't know
what I was thinking was the last person
he'd want to see for all I knew I could
have crippled him for life
yes
I'll do something I had to do
had to could
[Music]
well
what
yeah hello
stop doing that steps going to give me a
smacker on my lips Oh ball it's you
bullet little weird dream I know we're
topsy-turvy dream I don't know what
happened oh I'm back at the campsite oh
good goody goody gumdrops
another Ebola what are you what's okay
what's okay maybe it's not a boy it
might not be okay I don't know how to
tell you this but I had some weird
dreams a lot older a lot a lot of sense
hey well you're a good boy you're a good
boy Bullock you're a good boy you're
good it's okay boy
easy easy boys you want to eat hey buddy
what about what about a dog snack huh
now's not a good time uh-huh yeah so you
say okay
oh is this oh like mr. moose man there
hey can't you stop whispering at me mr.
bundle of sticks i'ma show you the
business oh you want me to show you the
business come on let's show you don't
make me do it nobody yeah
I don't know it feels good Marius
alright okay um I'm gonna leave this one
right here ich seems like as good a
place as any to leave this this game is
like I've played some surreal games this
game is surreal cranked up to like 9000
it just beyond surreal
Theodore McKinnon my father was a
lumberjack when I was a child he would
often take me to the sawmill in the
Black Hills forest to tell me stories of
the monsters and witches who lived there
I returned to that place almost 40 years
it looked exactly how I remember it
except for its haunting emptiness no it
was telling the stories and fearsome
critters anymore there was not a single
soul to pass the legends on the logging
company disbanded in the old sawmill was
left to rot but I could not simply let
it be forgotten now before it revealed
its secrets to me not before I learned
what drove my father to take his own
life
all right good great yeah that's a good
parting thought to leave you guys with
so thank you everybody so much for
watching
hope you're enjoying it as we get
farther into the woods it seems like
things just get weirder and weirder but
I love the aesthetic and I love what we
got going on here so thank you everybody
so much for watching and as always see
you in the next video bye-bye
[Music]